ever wonder why pacifism is deeply
embedded in the Japanese identity
well after world war two decimated
Imperial Japan wiped out two cities with
the atom bomb and the country was
occupied by the United States
that's when Japan created a new
constitution it includes article 9 the
peace clause it basically says that the
Japanese people won't ever threaten or
use force to settle international
disputes it also says that they won't
maintain land sea and air forces despite
this Japan keeps her so-called
self-defense force in 2014 Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a approved a
reinterpretation of article 9 allowing
for collective self-defense
that means Japan can send troops and
equipment you know those things that
enable fighting to aid allies during war
so after more than half a century of
pacifist foreign policy does this
suggest Japan's returning to its
military past
you